le président de la république d'une part
que le premier ministre devant votre
assemblée en début de semaine ont
annoncé des annulations de charges pour
les indépendants pour les commerces pour
les entreprises qui sont les plus
touchés par la crise notamment pour ceux
de ses commerces ses de ces entreprises
qui ont eu à connaître des fermetures de
la part du gouvernement qu'il soit dans
l'arrêté qu'a pris le gouvernement au
lendemain du 15 mars
ou alors du fait effectivement des
difficultés sanitaires extrêmement forte
que ces commerces aussi indépendants ont
eu à connaître
je voudrais d'abord préciser ici comme
j'ai pu le faire devant la commission
des affaires sociales à la demande du
président me le dire à quel point c'est
tout à fait originale dans l'histoire de
la protection sociale il n'y a jamais eu
d'annulation de charges pour des
secteurs y en a eu sur des zones
territoriales c'était le cas de saint
barth saint martin au moment de délire
mal parfois le parlement décide de le
faire lui-même sur les ederer par
exemple mais jamais par secteur
qu'allons-nous faire une annulation
totale de charges entre le 15 mai et
autres le 15 mars pardon et le 15 juin
pour l'ensemble du secteur hôtellerie
restauration tourisme arts et spectacles
culture sport pour toutes les
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
et puis une annulation pour tout secteur
confondu pour toute entreprise de moins
de dix salariés qui ont dû fermer
pour prendre l'exemple des coiffeurs
évidemment que chacun connaît et sans
doute que tout le monde espère désormais
la réouverture c'est effectivement un
point très important c'est un contre ce
n'était pas une attaque ad hominem
monsieur le président bah exactement
c'était tout à fait personnel aussi
comme réflexion je vais dire à monsieur
7h bargeton que tous ces commerces qu'on
était obligé de fermer tous et
indépendant en plus évidemment de ce que
vous avez évoqué sur les indépendants et
je devrais essayer dire qu'il ya six
cent soixante mille indépendant qui pour
le compte du mois d'avril ont demandé
l'aide c'est à dire au bout de six jours
plus de la moitié de ce qui a été
demandé au mois de mars on est bien la
demande est extrêmement forte
effectivement ces annulations de charge
seront complètes j'aurai l'occasion avec
mon collègue louise à sentel et
solidarité monsieur le président vous
avez raison j'aurai l'occasion de
pouvoir préciser dans les jours qui
viennent avec les représentants
professionnels la modalités exactes de
ces annulations qui n'ont jamais existé
jusqu'à
la santé